hi my name is Mark and I'm the CEO and
founder of tungo it's a really exciting
day for us today one year of work that
we've been doing with IBM and now is now
available for everybody to start using
we are making available our notes
connector for everyone to start using it
worldwide so how does it work well
tungle is a scheduling service we take
the pain out of scheduling you know all
the emails back and forth that you go
through to find time to meet with one or
many people whether they're inside your
office or not well that's the pain that
we solve and let me show you how we
actually do
it so when you first sign up to tungle
which is a free account you get your own
tungle me URL so mine is tungle
mmark and so what we do once you get it
is you really get to customize it the
way you like it so I put my picture on
it I really linked it to my different
social networks but what's really cool
is that I really got to set the times
that I want to make myself available for
meetings so for example I took out so
that every week on Monday mornings
nobody can schedule a meeting with me
because I have my management meetings I
have all my marketing meetings and so on
and also on Friday afternoon my head is
not at having meetings so I really took
out my Friday afternoons and I really
got to say you know what I want meetings
from 8:30 to 5:30 and and so on so the
other thing and this is where the power
of the notes connector really fits in is
that as you have events in your noes
calendar it is automatically sync with
tongle so you don't need to think about
oh no I'll get double booked because I
made myself available on tungle no what
it does it automatically takes out the
times that you set as busy in your
calendar and as you move stuff around in
your calendar it will automatically
update this page for you so when someone
wants to meet with me what I do is I
send them to tungle mmark it's
automatically formatted for their time
zone so if they're on the West Coast or
if they're in Europe it will
automatically display these times here
based on their time zone so when someone
wants to meet with me they get to this
URL and then they get to pick multiple
times to schedule a meeting with me and
then I'll get an email saying hey Bob
wants to meet with you and here are the
times that he's proposing to meet with
you so I get to pick the time that works
best for me it puts it in my calendar
they automatically receive the uh email
confirmation and the meeting is booked
so it's pretty powerful but what's
happening is that tungle is spreading
really rapidly and more and more people
were getting their pages and so what
we've created is if you know the IDE of
the different people that are uh
scheduling meetings you can actually
just start superimposing them on top of
yours so for example let me add jaku rod
and Aaron here and as I add their name
here you'll see the aggregate
availability of all these four different
people so I'm a notes user jauza
Outlook user ry's an IAL user and
Aaron's a Google Calendar user and we're
all in different system but now I can
see the aggregate availability of all of
us so if I wanted to schedule a meeting
with all of us I just pick a time that
works for us and I book it it's pretty
straightforward now let me show you what
it looks like within the notes
environment so when you install the
widget which B takes a few seconds you
basically just drag it into the widget
section it will automatically sync it
your sync your Notes Calendar with
tungle and you don't need to manually do
it as you move stuff around as you add
more events into your notes calendar
tungle is automatically updated for you
now most of meetings are initiated by an
email that you receive so I received an
email from Jean Philip and in the past
what I would have done is I would
probably hit reply and say hey JP how
about Monday looking at my calendar
looking back and forth and most of the
times that I would have probably propose
are not good good because he'll be busy
so instead what you can do instead of
hitting reply you just hit on the
schedule button and what that does it
opens up a window within your notes
environment and it prepopulates the
subject with the subject of the email so
you don't have to type it in edit
populates as well everybody that was in
the two and the
CC and so now what's even more powerful
is because I was already sharing my
calendar with Aon and Rod their their
events are shown here now Aon I just see
her free busy because that's what she
accepted to share with me but Rod I can
actually see the detail of his calendar
because that's what he's accepted to
share with me so if I wanted to schedule
a meeting I can now start proposing
multiple times not just one but multiple
times and allow them to pick the times
that work best for them so that we can
find a time to meet so it's pretty
powerful there's a lot more to tungle
and I invite you to try it out it is a
free service again tungle do me let us
know what you think about it and enjoy
tongling